PIERS MORGAN: With
other countries now
steaming past America, what
is the number one thing
you want to see whoever wins
the next election do about this?
SALMAN KHAN: I
think there's going
to be a broad push to making
classrooms more human.
And when you have 42
people or 30 people
or even 20 people in a room
and it's all about a lecture,
no matter how good you
get that ratio down,
it's still a passive experience.
It's what we all went through.
You're looking at a clock,
waiting for the period to end.
And so what we're
talking about is
technology not to replace what's
happening in the classroom,
but to make the
classroom better.
If lectures can happen
at a student's own pace,
if a lot of the problem
solving can happen,
can we use the class
time for interaction
between the peers, interaction
between the teacher?
So even if you have the
unfortunate situation
of 42 students, at least let
them interact with each other.
And let them teach each other.
Let them have more opportunities
to actually interact
with the teacher.
PIERS MORGAN: But
is the right move
forward for kids to be
doing as much work at home
as they do at
school, and doing it
on computers, which is their
natural habitat, anyway?
SALMAN KHAN: No.
I think actually one
of the big problems--
and I talk a lot
about this-- is we
have this culture
of homework that
creates this illusion of rigor.
Oh, we're not good enough?
The Estonians are beating
us at factoring polynomials?
More homework.
And all the studies
actually point to, well,
the single biggest
determinants of student success
are dinner with their
parents and sleeping.
And homework, if
it's too much of it,
directly goes against
both of those things.
And so we've been working
with a lot of schools.
What we're seeing
is if you actually
allow more engagement
in the classroom,
you allow students to
learn at their own pace,
they actually learn
much, much more.